9h le matin à tous arnaud klaauw ma dans
le sud des états unis et sont venus de
partout et font la file dans le froid
dix mille personnes viennent voir la
vedette politique de l'heure dans notre
choix ces républicains voient dans notre
chambre comme leur prochain président
ces quelques manifestants lui reproche
ses propos racistes sur les musulmans et
les mexicains mais là tu chantes mais
mia est plus forte que tout ici
c'est dans un aréna plein à craquer que
le meneur chez les républicains fait son
entrée dans notre chambre joue la carte
de l'antipolitique siens ses partisans
en ont assez des politiciens
professionnels à washington il
ridiculise tout le monde il veut bâtir
un mur à la frontière du mexique pour
freiner l'immigration illégale
il se présente comme le sauveur des
valeurs américaines un discours qui
séduit cette femme qui a toujours voté
pour le parti démocrate
l'arrivée dans la course de ce magna de
l'immobilier à déstabiliser le parti
républicain
même les stratèges les plus aguerris en
perdent leur latin
si messieurs trempe devient de candidats
du parti républicain le parti vad va
avoir un problème énorme tianwan stein a
conseillé l'ex président george bush
père
il craint que donald trump discrédite la
marque républicaine c'est pas un homme
sérieux c'est pas quelqu'un qui tout
tourne autour de lui autour de sa
personnalité autour de ces réactions 7
c'est un c'est un génie du théâtre
wolf ce sondeur a interviewé quatre
groupes de partisans de trump pour
tenter de mieux comprendre le phénomène
il en ressort que beaucoup d'américains
n'en peuvent plus de la paralysie
politique au congrès ils sont prêts à
courir le risque avec trump
après le discours de donald trump arnaud
klaauw ma ce couple hésite tout de même
encore à l'appuyer
il y a 6 mois
tous les experts prédisaient la mort
politique de donald trump
à quelques jours des caucus de l'iowa
tous se demande qui pourra l'arrêter et
comment
oui